hallo mein Name ist Luca meine Damen und
Herren da die Flaggen erraten Videos auf
meinem YouTube-Kanal immer sehr gut
ankam weil wir beiden extrem Blut sind
moin ich bin selfie auch dabei heute wir
haben uns auf jeden Fall gedacht dass
wir jetzt mal wieder ein paar Flaggen
erraten werden wovon allerdings wir
einige auch schon hatten dementsprechend
schauen wir ob wir jetzt mittlerweile
wissen und uns erinnern können was das
für Flaggen von welchen Ländern waren
los geht's
sagen
das sieht aus wie ein Paraguayer in der
Mitte das ist ein Paraguay
ein Tier oder
als Baum gefallen oder was in meinen
Augen ist das irgendwas in Südamerika
auf jeden Fall dementsprechend ähm sage
ich es ist schon es könnte Nachbarland
von Argentinien sein ich sage Kamerun
oder so
viel hinter der Kamera was ist es
noch nie gehört Bruder
das ist
China ja ich sage auch China 100% China
wir sind sicher
was ist denn
musst du gehen raus
das ist Irland
definitiv Irland ich weiß es dass es
Irland ist weil Deutschland
[Musik]
nur deswegen verbinde ich ihr Land damit
was denkst
Basketballspieler
UFC Fighter gut mein Fehler
erster Punkt
[Musik]
Schweden
nee Spaß
das ist
[Musik]
Paraguay
das ist zu 100% Paraguay 20 Sekunden
später
Wales
komplett aus
das ist
das Japan 100%
das ist richtig damit kommen wir zum
Sponsor des heutigen Videos du weißt
natürlich was aus Japan kommt richtig
richtig was Pokémon Pokémon ihr wisst ja
glaube ich alle dass ich ein riesen
Pokémon Fan bin seit meiner Kindheit ich
habe auch meinen Sammelalbum hier
mitgebracht ich glaube jeder kennt
Pokémon das muss man glaube ich nicht
erklären ich habe immer gewünscht dass
man selber mit so Pokémon aufwächst aber
deswegen jemand aufgefallen wir haben ja
Pokémon und unsere Welt wir haben ja
auch Tauben wir haben ja auch Giraffen
alles mögliche wir haben ja Pokémon auf
unsere Erde darum soll es allerdings
nicht gehen Ich bin auf jeden Fall ein
riesen Pokémon Fan deswegen freue ich
mich sehr heute mit Pokémon zusammen
eine Kooperation in diesem Flaggen Video
zu machen denn aktuell läuft sehr coole
Aktion und zwar der Pokémon TCG
sammelwettbewerb damit habt ihr nämlich
die Chance eure Sammelkarten hochzuladen
auf der Webseite die sich logischerweise
wo befindet
jede Website ist im Internet aber dies
in der Infobox vom Video
auf der Website auf jeden Fall eure
Pokémon Sammelkarten eure kompletten
Alben hochladen wenn ich jetzt schon
wieder die Sachen sind ne oder ich habe
sogar einen Youtube ich weiß nicht wo
das ist
hier krass ne sind sehr wenig Wert meine
Karten ich habe darüber schon mal ein
Video gemacht aber sind sehr sehr schön
aus auf jeden Fall könnt ihr eure
Pokémon Sammelkarten hochladen auf der
Webseite hier unten in der
Videobeschreibung findet und dann mit
anderen Pokémon Trainern aus der Welt
teilen könnt euch angucken was andere so
Versammlungen haben ich werde euch meine
Sammlung auf jeden Fall demnächst mal in
einem Twitch Livestream zeigen und da
werden wir uns auch zusammen im
Livestream Sander du bist dabei wir
werden auch ein cooles Spiel spielen und
so deswegen schaltet auf jeden Fall ein
alle weiteren Infos folgen und da werden
wir euch uns auch einige von euren
hochgeladenen Sammlungen auf der Website
gemeinsam im Stream anschauen und auch
noch eine ganz kurze Info beim Hochladen
geht's nicht darum dass die teuersten
oder krassesten oder seltensten Karten
sondern einfach nur darum dass ihr eure
Karten hochladet auch wenn die keine
Ahnung total alt sind oder nichts wert
sind oder so das ist komplett egal meine
sind ja auch nicht viel wert es gibt
einfach nur darum so ein bisschen die
Begeisterung zu teilen zu schauen was
wir da hochlädt und deswegen warten
sogar tatsächlich auch geile Preise man
kann unzählige Booster gewinnen wie zum
Beispiel kam mit sieben Booster den
Purpur Booster das kennst du
wahrscheinlich nicht ne okay so tief
drin auch nicht danke schön auf jeden
Fall dann Pokémon für sponsern ist
heutigen Videos danke für euren Support
für eure Unterstützung und ihr findet
selbstverständlich einen Link oben in
der Infobox also klick da drauf lade
eure Sammelkarten hoch und dann werdet
ihr vielleicht in meinem Livestream mit
dabei sein wenn andere und euch euch
bewerten und eure Booster uns anschauen
weiter geht's
ist Litauen
Serbien boah ich will auch sagen sehr
wenige Montenegro für mich
Montenegro nicht zusammen
was genau
das ist ähm
das ist Paraguay
ich bleibe da Serbien
ja knapp daneben ist auch vorbei
viele
nicht so witzig das ist genau don't talk
to me leise
ähm
Korea Nordkorea Südkorea
richtig ich habe doch so
scheiße
Land das ist New Zealand oh mein Gott
das ist nun
sagt man New Zealand auch in
Deutschland an Neuseeland Neuseeland
zu peinlich ich gehe nach Hause einmal
ne kann man rückgängig machen das ist
schick mal ja ich weiß was es ist
das ist jetzt nämlich hat die Leute
denken das ist Griechenland falsch
gedacht
ist nämlich
ähm Sansibar
muss los Bruder ich gebe dir noch einen
Versuch
jetzt gehe ich nach Hause es macht
keinen Sinn Hongkong
wieder lustig
Palästinenser
das Sitze sagt nicht das ist auch eine
Stadt alles die Mensa ist kein Land
ich weiß es selber nicht ich glaube aber
das ist irgendwas in Afrika ich würde
sagen dass das
ich habe also wirklich
Nicaragua nee nee hat eine schon
ich sag auch Nigeria
[Musik]
das weiß ich definitiv ja sag doch jetzt
mal ich bin immer die Erste die Anfänger
[Musik]
dann sagen wir es aber wenn wenn wenn
ich halt zuerst sage dann kriegst okay 3
2 1 Schottland
Peru kannst du das Foto vom Album Cover
von mero sein
Peru
Perus gut es ist auch ich glaube ich
schließe mich da an Traum Bruder
[Musik]
Riss vom eigenen Land mit auf die Flagge
ich glaube das kann nur ein verrücktes
Land sein und ich sage es ist Madagaskar
nein
das ist Island nee das ist Lettland nein
lettland ist auf gar keinen dunkelblaue
Flagge du hast hier eine weiße
eisberginsel da das Titanic ne du hast
einen weißen Eisberg im blauen Wasser
das muss Island sein was ist die
Hauptstadt von Island was die Hauptstadt
von Island keine Ahnung
ich war aber nah dran mit Island
irgendwann
[Musik]
da
nächste mit Speedrun eine Sekunde direkt
werden wir auch wieder reinhauen
Lichtenstein Kroatien Kroatien ich bin
da es ist wirklich groß ich weiß doch
wieder interessant unter dem rot-weiß
einfach Holland gewesen Niederlande
Peru Niederlande doch gerade noch gesagt
das ist peinlich wenn du das jetzt sagst
dann sage ich Luxemburg
meine Damen und Herren an der Stelle
würden wir uns auch beenden Danke schön
an Pokémon für die tatkräftige
Unterstützung lade wie bereits gesagt
eure Sammelkarten gerne hoch auf der
Website die ihr unten in der
Videobeschreibung eingeblendet seht
Sarah und ich machen weil ein Livestream
werden dann so ein bisschen darauf
reagieren was ihr dort so hochgeladen
habt lasst einen Daumen hoch oder wie es
euch gefallen hat abonniert meinen Kanal
und klickt auf die Glocke weitere Videos
nicht zu verpassen ich fahre jetzt
tatsächlich mit dem Fahrrad zum Sport